france inter 17h04 radioscopie jacques
chancel
non
bon
radioscopie
radioscopie daniel barenboim jacques
chancel
vos parents sont venus de russie vous
est né un argentine
vous êtes installé en angleterre
maintenant vous vivez à paris alors où
sont vos racines
pour moi ce gitan c'est bien clair par
la haute définition
non je ne me parait il n'y a pas de race
de tout maintenant est un non sens large
non me paraissait sur le site installé
en israël 1 52 jeunes considèrent
israélien je conserve toujours ma
nationalité
vous êtes d'israël mais vous n'êtes pas
un homme de nulle part
vous appartenez à un pays j'avais cru
comprendre que vous étiez de nulle part
ah non non non non je fais tout tout mes
études à votre coin de terre c'est quand
même là endroit où vous dirigez un orque
mais c'est la semaine c'est là que vous
êtes bien c'est votre pays
la scène air france à ce moment-là il y
a deux grandes salles part il ya le
palais des congrès il y à pas les 10h12
aimeriez jouer au palais des sports
si jamais allé je connais pas vous voyez
à peu prend vous allez parler non oui le
théâtre des champs elysées que vous
préférez une grande salle une petite
salle l'idéal ce serait une salle
strictement pour le concert de 2500 de
1800 places ça c'est l'idéal mais
l'idéal ça n'existe pas nous on la
réalité la réalité nous avons une salle
de 3700 tour 1800 places où les choses
sont vraiment bien c'est la qualité de
son est très bonne la salle était un peu
grande et c'est pour ça que nous avons
fait beaucoup de recherches pour
améliorer l'acoustique
je crois que nous l'avons amélioré
beaucoup et c'est pas encore fini mais
l'idéal d'une salle serait 6000 places
parce qu'à ce moment là on pourrait
réduire le prix des places où l'idéal
point de vue commercial oui et du port
louis et acoustique vous y pensez
parfois au côté commercial nous devons
nous devons bien sûr c'est ça le
problème s'il ne sait pas quand nous
avons la possibilité de jouer devant
4000 personnes au palais des congrès
c'est pas la même chose comme jouer
devant 1500 champs-elysées